la fertilización es la historia épica de
un solo espermatozoide que se enfrenta a
increíbles obstáculos para unirse con un
óvulo y formar una nueva vida humana es
la historia de todos nosotros
durante la relación sexual unos 300
millones de espermatozoides entran en la
vagina
[Música]
después millones de ellos fluyen fuera
de la vagina
o mueren en su ambiente ácido sin
embargo muchos sobreviven debido a los
elementos de protección brindados por el
líquido que los rodea
luego el esperma debe pasar a través del
cuello del útero una abertura en el
útero por lo general este se mantiene
bien cerrado pero aquí el cuello uterino
está abierto durante unos días mientras
que la mujer óvulo
el esperma nada a través de la mucosidad
cervical que ha adquirido una
consistencia más líquida para facilitar
el paso
una vez en el interior del cuello del
útero el esperma sigue nadando hacia el
útero aunque millones morirán tratando
de hacerlo a través de la mucosidad
algunos espermatozoides se quedan atrás
atrapados en los pliegues del cuello del
útero pero luego pueden continuar el
viaje como un respaldo del primer grupo
en el interior del útero las
contracciones uterinas musculares ayudan
a los espermatozoides en su viaje hacia
el óvulo sin embargo las células
residentes del sistema inmunológico de
la mujer confunden el esperma con
invasores extraños y así destruyen miles
de espermatozoides más
luego la mitad de la cabeza del
espermatozoide ingresa en la trompa de
falopio mientras que la otra mitad nada
hacia el tubo que contiene el óvulo
fertilizado ahora sólo unos cuantos
miles quedan dentro de la trompa de
falopio minúsculos cilios empujan el
óvulo hacia el útero para continuar los
espermatozoides deben surgir contra este
movimiento para llegar al óvulo algunos
espermatozoides se quedan atrapados en
los cilios y mueren durante esta parte
del viaje químicos en el tracto
reproductivo hacen que las membranas que
cubren las cabezas de los
espermatozoides cambien como resultado
los espermatozoides se vuelven
hiperactivos y nadan más duro y más
rápido hacia su destino
por fin el espermatozoide llega al óvulo
[Música]
sólo unas pocas docenas de los 300
millones de espermatozoides originales
que dan el huevo está cubierto por una
capa de células llamada corona radiata
el esperma debe empujar a través de esta
capa para llegar a la capa exterior del
óvulo la zona pelúcida cuando el
espermatozoide llega a la zona pelúcida
se une a unos receptores especializados
de espermatozoides en la superficie lo
que causa que su sacro somas liberen
enzimas digestivas lo que permite que
los espermatozoides se introduzcan en la
capa
dentro de la zona pelúcida hay un
espacio estrecho y lleno de líquido
justo afuera de la membrana de la célula
del óvulo el primer espermatozoide en
hacer contacto fertilizar el óvulo
después de un viaje peligroso contra
obstáculos increíbles un solo
espermatozoide se une a la membrana de
la célula del óvulo dentro de unos pocos
minutos sus membranas externas se unen y
el óvulo jala el espermatozoide hacia
adentro este evento causa cambios en la
membrana del óvulo que impiden que los
otros espermatozoides se adhieran a ella
luego el óvulo libera químicos que
empujan a otros espermatozoides fuera
del óvulo y crea una membrana de
fecundación impenetrable a medida que la
reacción se propaga hacia el exterior la
zona pelúcida se endurece atrapando a
cualquier espermatozoide que tenga la
mala suerte de quedarse atrapado en el
interior
afuera del óvulo los espermatozoides ya
no son capaces de unirse a la zona
pelúcida
mientras tanto en el interior del óvulo
el ajustado material genético masculino
se extiende
[Música]
se forma una nueva membrana alrededor
del material genético creando el pro
núcleo masculino
adentro el material genético se vuelve a
formar en los 23 cromosomas el material
genético femenino despertado por la
fusión del espermatozoide con el óvulo
termina por dividirse dando como
resultado el pro núcleo femenino que
también contiene 23 cromosomas
mientras los núcleos masculino y
femenino forman hilos parecidos a los de
la tela de araña llamados microtúbulos
se atraen entre ellos los dos conjuntos
de cromosomas se unen completando el
proceso de fertilización en este momento
surge un único código genético el cual
determina instantáneamente el género el
color de pelo y de ojos y cientos de
otras características
esta célula nueva única el cigoto es el
comienzo de un nuevo ser humano y ahora
los cilios de las trompas de falopio
llevan suavemente el cigoto hacia el
útero donde él o ella se implanta en el
revestimiento uterino creciendo y
madurando durante los próximos nueve
meses hasta el momento de su nacimiento
[Música]